يعني انا للحقيقه في هذا اللقاء الذي
جمعني مع
اعضاء هذه المنصه من كايصيد مركز الملك
عبدالله رحمه الله
كنت في غايه السرور لانني رايت يعني
مجموعه
متضامنه
يجمعها حب الله سبحانه وتعالى
وكان مركز الملك عبد الله رحمه الله
يعني هو السباق الى هذه
الى هذه الصيغه التي تجمع
اهل الديانات والحوار والثقافات
ووجدت فيها نموذجا يعني
سابقا لكل ما حصل فيما بعد لانه كان سباق
فعلا مركز
الى مثل هذه اللقاءات ومثل هذه الاجتماعات
بين القيادات الدينيه والدعوه الى الحوار
لمختلف الثقافات والمذاهب والطوائف
فهذا النموذج يعني هو اصبح فيما بعد
يدعى اليه عالميا في كل المنتديات وفي
كثير من الدول
اعتمدوا هذا المنهج الذي بناه مركز الملك
عبد الله في فيينا رحمه الله
فهذا النموذج يعني
يمكن ان يتسع وان يعني يؤثر لانه ينشر
ثقافه الحوار والتواصل والمحبه والتلاقي
وذكرني يعني
اجتماعهم على اختلاف مذاهبهم واجيانهم
وثقافاتهم
ذكرني بالحديث الشريف الذي يقول
المتحابون في الله على منابر في يوم
القيامه او انهم يدخلون الجنه بغير حساب
هذا النموذج جمعته المحبه في الله وفي
الانسانيه هذا يمكن ان نعقد عليه الامال
الكبيره في نشر خطاب المحبه لمواجهه خطاب
الكراهه وثقافتها